i started playing music when i was 10
years old
and went and um
through high school and and one of the
things that influenced me the most was
i grew up in lakeland florida
and in lakeland around 1974 giving away
my age 59
they had created what's called the
lakeland civic center so all of the
major bands
commodores first wanted fire
oh everyone came through
and the tickets were at the time they're
not where they have hyped now but
they're at the time where as a kid you
can mow some lawns
and buy a ticket and go see your your
favorite band
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is all about jazz and in the
workplace and engineering and everything
in between it's really a special episode
with a fascinating conversation with
gerald leonard a professional musician
but also a real thought leader in the
way workplaces can improve agility and
improve the work of teams
a professional bassist gerald j leonard
offers a unique approach to
accomplishing more productivity in the
workplace
gerald is an international keynote
bassist and culture change expert his
programs integrate music productivity
workplace culture and neuroscience
gerald leonard is the author of culture
is the base seven steps to creating high
performing teams listed on entrepreneur
magazine as one of the top 15 books on
business culture that you need to read
today and the book workplace jazz how to
improvise listed on human resources
online as one of the top 10 must-read hr
books gerald is the ceo of principles of
execution dba turnberry premier a
strategic project portfolio management
culture change and i.t consulting firm
with over 20 years of experience working
with large federal and state governments
and multinational corporations
gerald j leonard thank you so much for
joining me from alabama how are you
i'm doing well michael how are you
i'm doing fantastic because we're going
to be talking about the intersection of
music
thinking being a you know an all-rounded
person and leadership especially when it
comes to the workplace and so we're
talking about a few of my really
favorite things here
gerald i see
keyboard behind you i see the word
culture and the word bass yes how how do
these things
even
come up together in the same
place in your in your office what i
assume
well yeah as you can see this is my this
is my office this is my business office
and my music office uh behind me i have
a uh upright electric upright base and a
couple of electric bases as well as the
keyboard and uh studio equipment
um
i started playing music when i was 10
years old
and went and um
through high school and and one of the
things that influenced me the most was
i grew up in lakeland florida and in
lakeland around 1974 giving away my age
they had created what's called the
lakeland civic center so all of the
major bands
commodores first wanted fire
oh everyone came through
and the tickets were at the time they're
they're not where they have hype now but
they're at the time where as a kid you
could mow some lawns
and buy a ticket and go see your your
favorite band
incredible that wasn't a amazing
influence on me so i went and did my
bachelor's and master's uh study at
cincinnati conservatory got a chance to
play carnegie hall
all in grad school
um wow went to new york uh studied with
my teachers teacher up in new york a guy
named david walter who um who taught it
uh
on juilliard and the manhattan school of
music and i slept my base down to julia
take lessons for him for about a year
and played professionally in new york
and then did some ministry work had a
family and you know made a decision i
really didn't want to be on the road so
i was playing locally
um
and that's when i got into i.t
into technology into business
but i kept playing music because that
was my love that was what i love to do
but i was responsible from the
standpoint of that's how i go that's how
i grew up my dad was always there and i
saw myself as hey i have kids now i'm
going to be there i'm going to be in
their lives i don't want to be i don't
want to be you know the weekend dad kind
of thing or the doing the weekday for a
couple of days and then you're out
playing gigs
um
and those two careers grew side by side
and i had already had my master's so i
went and did a lot of certifications and
project manager certifications and
business certifications
and
later on as my kids were growing up they
begin to get more into music as well
so it brought music full force back into
my life in a major way besides just
playing some gigs here and there and
doing a lot of different things that i
was doing
um
i began to see the merger between the
two and i think what was really
interesting
was
going and playing a concert or a show or
recording
and then going and doing some consulting
some business work and i started seeing
the similarities between
a great performance in music
and a great project in business
and that the
personality the character of the team
the flavor um you know you're a musician
so you know when you get together with
other musicians there's like a
brotherhood
irregardless of where you come from
irregardless of what language you speak
in regards to what color you are there's
an emotional brotherhood that happens
our sisterhood that happens when you get
together and play music it's a spiritual
connection that you develop
and what i found was that
business teams where people were really
good at what they did but were willing
to leave their ego at the door
think about the big picture
would normally develop the same kind of
brother or sisterhood
uh camaraderie
and it really made a difference in the
types of projects and you'll find that a
lot of developers software developers
are musicians as well
because music develops the mathematical
part of the brain
and it also creates something called
whole brain integration
now what does that mean that i read
about my book well whole brand
integration
um the folks a couple of folks that had
that were like western churchill
and henry ford
henry ford was also a trained violinist
in fact really at the beginning of his
career and and throughout his life he
owned the largest collection of
classical um uh italian violins
in the united states wow and he's a
classical trained musician besides being
you know the founder of four voters
well winston churchill was a prolific
painter
besides being the prime minister of
the uk
but both of these gentlemen had to face
major challenges in their life and they
needed the ability to think big picture
as well as details and what whole brain
integration gives you
um is the ability to use your right
brain and your left brain simultaneously
and in the bill of our brains we have
what's called a corpus colossal it's a
lot of fibers that connect both
hemispheres
and
when as a musician when you're either
reading music or playing music and
you're playing the instrument and you're
looking at and you're you're connecting
you are using your right brain and your
left brain both are working
simultaneously
so as you tr as you train as a musician
you naturally develop what's called
whole brain integration where your brain
both hemispheres are actively working at
the same time
and it gives you the ability in life to
see the big picture
of a goal or something that you want to
accomplish
while at the same time
being very
aware
and intimately uh involved in the
details
i have to ask gerald you know it sounds
incredible i mean this sounds like the
holy grail of what any person would want
for themselves right
yeah i don't see
and everybody talking to me about how
you know we need to to you know practice
our instruments and to play music and
have a love for art so that we can
become better engineers you know i'm
here you know i've been doing software
engineering for a while i've also been a
saxophone player and that is that is
mainly things to my family but
but i've never
had somebody come up to me and tell me
if you want to be a better software
engineer you should go and study
piano or or continue playing the
saxophone why is this you know so what
have you discovered or what what is
happening here that is not trivial for
for a lot of people to sort of
conceptualize well if you look at if you
look at a lot of um
current research in neuroscience
um they're beginning to discover the
power of music
on the brain
i was reading an article the other day
uh off of late then about um one uh a
neuroscience um
magazine that i follow on linkedin and
they had an article about how
music
influences
our working memory
in long-term and short-term memory how
it impacts it because if you think about
it as a musician
you learn pieces of music right and you
let's say you learn a concerto or you
learn some jazz or you learn a rock and
roll song well you have to keep that
song in your working memory as you're
playing it you got to keep the chord
changes you got to keep the phrases that
you're going to play well while you're
doing that and you're having fun doing
it you're actually developing
the neurological pathways
for a stronger working memory
and
it's the same pathways that the majority
of math of your math thinking
happens in that same part of the brain
and so i'm not sure and i think you know
what again what i've realized is in just
my experiences
there are a lot of musicians
or a lot of developers who i turn around
and find out that they are musicians
right a lot of musicians are they it's
easy for them to get into computers and
become software developers
because music is very logical
right
it's very logical it's either three four
four four five eight you know it's
there's there's a pattern
and everything has to fit
yeah i think everything is a structure
at the same time
musical is very improvisational sure
from a classical standpoint even even if
you're playing a bach concerto you get
yo-yo ma and you get isaac pearlman to
play the same concerto it's going to
sound different because they're going to
have a different interpretation they may
play the same exact notes but they may
phrase the notes differently they may
use more vibrato on one note than the
other it's their interpretation of that
piece
so that's improvisation even at a macro
level and it sounds like this is going
looking back to what you were mentioning
before about our ability to both have
detail oriented mindset but also higher
level understanding of what is our
larger interpretation of this piece of
the story that we're telling and now
let's execute on details while having
both logic
and the creativity and the
improvisational capacity right exactly
in fact did you know that einstein was
also a musician
i did not know that he was also a
musician so if you think about it it's
like some of the greatest thinkers in
the world
have a very strong musical background
so in that case
we should all be learning music exactly
now and so one of my pet peeves is with
the school system is when they go well
we got to cut back on the budget so
let's do what let's take out
band class
exactly
and they think well you know that's
unnecessary we need to do more
math and science and reading right i
mean it felt at least to me well and
i've been i was in band class the entire
um you know the entire uh my entire
school school and i'd always still felt
that it was treated as more of an
elective and i'm pretty sure it's called
an elective it's not like a core
science or a core requirement right
right but if but if educators understood
the neural science and the
mental development that happens with
music
to me music would become a core
requirement
for any
you know
country or any organization that really
wants to
to develop its people at the highest
level and whether they become and what's
interesting about whole brain
integration the only other way to get
cold rate integration is you have to be
somebody like the dalai lama who
meditates for 30 years and literally
just spend hours and hours and hours
meditating
that will give you whole brain
integration that will develop the right
and left brain and create that
communication but it takes years to
develop that
music you develop it within
a very short period of time
that you begin to play and it doesn't
matter whether you are a professional or
an amateur as long as you are practicing
playing and performing
you know again doesn't mean that you're
playing at the highest level and you're
getting penny and you're playing with
carnegie hall
it's just that you're enjoying it but it
does develop that so i want to also talk
about that because i think that you know
something that can be very discouraging
is is how
how intimidating it is it is right and
you know i remember starting out it was
very little starting off and and i was
and i had the
huge privilege of growing up with a
brother who's
a
magician on the keyboard and he went to
juilliard and broadway and so it was
always very intimidating for me when i'm
saying like wow like his ability to
improvise and to understand this complex
piece
for me i turned to mathematical
equations and software engineering
because it was more clear to me what
were the steps that i need in order to
logically understand them so if you're
so given that your understanding of the
math and science world and the music
world
how can we overcome those barriers so
that we can reintroduce music as a core
part of how we grow up in this world
yeah one of my favorite musicians is
generally named victor wooden you're a
five-time graduating basis i had a
chance to meet him at a boot camp with
gerald easley and a few years ago
um and he wrote a couple of books in one
of his books he talks about
music as a language and victor was kind
of like yourself his brothers were very
talented musicians
and he was kind of like the little guy
you know little literally when i say a
little girl like five six years old
they gave him a little bass and he they
teach him how to play bass and
and he basically learned from being
around his brothers but if you think
about it
music is a language
now
obviously you speak english very very
well
did you grow up intimidated
to speak english
when your parents and your brother spoke
at a much higher level in fact they
could write english they could they
could speak it at a much higher level
they may even speak another language or
two but did you grow up intimidated
no no right because because you know and
here's the thing as a child speaking
you have a chance to perform and
practice with professionals all day long
all day long
right
and so that quickly helped you to grow
and figure out how to go from dada to
dad to putting all these different you
know phrases together even before you
knew the theory
right or what a noun was or what a verb
was music is the same way
so if we teach music it's almost like
the suzuki method of teaching violin
where you teach the child to play the
bible first
right you teach them about ear and teach
them by wrong that's how i learned
playing well not that i took the suzuki
method but i learned to play the guitar
in the bass by ear first
just just like and just playing music
and listening and finding the right note
and then trying to figure things out
later on as i began to get
better at playing
that's when i started studying and took
lessons and studied it in school
because that's some more natural way of
learning
we learned from professionals and we get
to speak and with a language like
like music or a language like
english german french italian
um our parents others who are experts
they're encouraging us they're not going
oh you said that wrong why'd you say it
that way you you know
what's wrong with you no they never say
that to us or you did that you played
that wrong they they simply go they just
encourage you to keep talking and keep
talking and what do you do you listen
and you imitate
and that's i mean i think that's
vocabulary
you know english obviously we learn to
speak
first we learn by ear
we learn by practicing and then we go
and study the theory behind grammar and
that only really comes to us at i guess
third grade right in where you actually
get into the the interesting details of
the language
software engineering the best software
engineers are the ones that will tell
you i didn't learn from a textbook i
learned it because i was passionate
about a project and i just started
playing around with it and then all of a
sudden i was working with somebody who
was better and i was getting code
reviews which is the performing with
professionals right from the engineering
side exactly
and in so many areas of life even with
leadership i was listening to um
satya nadella um he was teaching about
leadership in microsoft and just you
know what their model and they can they
express that they have a model now
called um
mcc then m is to model
coach and care
so if you think about it that's that's
kind of what we need from our our
leaders our teachers our coaches right
our trainers is we need someone that can
model the behavior
coach us in that behavior
and care about us as a human
being right not just did you do that
right did you get this done but to
really care about us and and and really
want the best for us personally and
professionally
but by but by having someone who's
leading the way in being a model
right we get a we get a pictorial
example and the other part of modeling
is that we all have something in
from a neurological standpoint called
mirror neurons
and in fact all animals have it
it's like that's why you see you know a
monkey or a bear or
you know orangutan or or cat or whatever
they you know the the the parent kind of
moves them along and shows them how to
hunt shows them how to to do whatever
they need to do from an instinctual
standpoint but the the cubs
model
and they they watch the parents it's
because even them at that within their
state
have mirror neurons
we as adults are we as human beings have
mirror neurons so that's why if you see
someone and they smile
you tend to want to smile too yeah
because that's your mirror
neurons right and by
by mimicking and putting the right
models in front of us
we can then model that we can we could
imitate that
and then we get coached and then you
know we we continually practice and and
it's the caring part that helps us to
nurture and grow and become our best
phenomenal that's the i i really love
that and you know this whole
conversation i think is it's very
uplifting for me and i think that i've
music has always had such a strong
part part in my life and i've always
questioned you know what what role does
the music actually play in my personal
development you know is this is this
something that i just really really
enjoy doing is this something that's
actually contributing
to other things that that i'm that i'm
doing and how are these elements
intersecting and i think that because
it's not intuitive i understand why most
people don't understand the connection
between software engineering and and
music i mean it's not a trivial it's not
a trivial intersection and and society
in general we're accustomed to having
clear differentiation you are right
brain you are left brained right i think
many many schools
you know promote their kids to take this
personality test to tell them what are
what they are right at that point they
tell okay you're going to be an engineer
you're going to be an artist okay well
that and that's that and and i think
that it's for me it it makes me
extremely curious to to continue diving
deep into this and ask some more
meaningful questions and so i draw that
i already want to request that i'm going
to do my research and i'm going to come
back in another episode and and ask you
some more meaningful questions to to
pick your brain because i it sounds like
you've been thinking about this for
quite some time and yeah the world is
picking up on it yes i i have like i
said i wrote about it a lot in my in my
latest book workplace jazz because each
of those principles are principles
that musicians uh are skills that
musicians develop you know whether it's
a positive attitude or
or the ability to use deliberate
practice or the whole idea of whole
brain integration
and then i provide research
um
from you know
peer-reviewed organizations like nih or
harvard or whatever to so that it's you
know empirical uh data that shows that
these things these skills actually have
a positive impact on us and their skills
that move the needle
it for you personally professionally and
organizational
i love it draw thank you so much for the
time and for the energy this was awesome
and i really look forward to sharing
this with everybody and then the first
person i'm going to share this with her
are my father and my brother so thank
you very very much and stay safe and
stay healthy you're more than welcome
thanks mike i really appreciate it
you